notre consultant militaire l'otan a donc
refusé la zone d'exclusion aérienne mais
il ya des armes qui sont livré à
l'ukraine en tout cas par les européens
de quel type d'armes s'agit-il alors
tout d'abord quand on parle de
effectivement l'otan a refusé en termes
d'organisation
défensive et ça a été rappelé par
stoltenberg et savoir que bien
évidemment en tant qu'organisation elle
ne pouvait être partie au conflit cc
s'expliquer aussi anthony blinken en
revanche les alliés de manière
individuelle se sont entendus
effectivement pour livrer du matériel de
guerre
aux ukrainiens alors en fait il ya
plusieurs choses qu'il faut ici
comprendre c'est en fait ce dont manque
l'ukraine c'est à la fois des
équipements défensifs l'équipement
défensives c'est-à-dire des casques et
des gilets pare-balles des équipements
dont les forces ukrainiennes ont besoin
parce que c'est un conflit de haute
intensité c'est à dire avec des pertes
avec la nécessité de re compléter et
puis on a tout simplement les
équipements dont on a besoin pour tout
simplement faire la guerre et là on
parle à la fois de munitions on parle
aussi parce que c'était très populaire à
la fois de missiles antichars et de
missiles antiaériens missiles antichars
puisque on se retrouve face à des unités
lourdes des unités blindées des unités
mécanisée et que bien évidemment
les ukrainiens cherche à compenser
là-dessus leur faiblesse en détruisant
les unités russes qu'ils affrontent et
puis la contestation du ciel se fait de
plus en plus par l' usage de missiles
antiaériens ce qu'on appelle destine
joueurs par exemple et là c'est pour
contester la supériorité aérienne à
moscou et éviter justement que dans des
actions coordonnées entre l'armée de
l'air russe et les forces terrestres on
puisse avancer trop rapidement capturés
des centres urbains capturer des centres
logistiques elles vous permettent elles
sont suffisantes pour éviter par un plat
prise de kiev ces armes alors sont elles
suffisantes en fait il ya deux problèmes
sait déjà où est-ce qu'elles arrivent
par qui est ce qu'elles sont prises on
est
parti elle son film en prises en oeuvre
ou est ce qu elles sont conduites par ce
que ça vous aura pas échappé que on a
finalement une guerre sur trois fronts
il ya le nord et le nord-est en gros de
la zone 2 qui va de kif jusqu à kharkiv
vous avez le donbass mais le donbass
c'est loin quand on est à vif il faut
aller s'il faut aller jusqu'à aux portes
de données est ce qu il ya quasiment
1500 km dans une zone qui est quand même
de deux guerres et puis vous avez le sud
où les forces sortie de cris mais sont
aussi ont pris personne avance peut-être
vers au dessin est donc quelque part
vous avez un enjeu sont elles
suffisantes ces armes probablement
peut-être sur un endroit ce n'est pas
rendre en tout cas difficiles rendent
plus difficile la presse d'une ville par
exemple ça peut rendre difficile mais là
encore il ya une dernière dimension
qu'il faut jamais négliger avoir des
armes c'est bien savoir s'en servir
c'est mieux et donc là encore un
entraînement militaire et on a vu hier
les questions qui se posaient autour de
la mobilisation des troupes ukrainienne
eh bien vous avez des reportages qui
montrent que tous les hommes qui sont
mobilisés ne sont pas intégrés dans des
unités de combat uniquement ceux qui ont
une formation et un entraînement déjà
avant le son justement parce que pour se
servir d'armes on ne peut pas se
permettre de perdre du temps merci
beaucoup guillaume la scuderia